good time was directed by the safty
brothers and stars of Robert Pattinson
and is the story of two brothers who try
to rob a bank but get caught one of them
does anyway and Robert Pattinson is free
trying to do everything in his power to
figure out how to get his brother out of
a really terrible Corrections Facility
it's a very bad area and he's positive
his brother is not gonna survive the
night so we follow him on a real-time
adventure in which he tries to do
everything in his power to get money to
bail his brother out the movie reminded
me of collateral in one specific way
it's one guys really crappy night and
all of his attempts to keep digging
himself out of a hole that he's dug for
himself and it's really riveting
especially because of the way it's
directed the safty brothers have a very
unique perspective on City nightlife
they use a lot of close-ups a lot of
long takes sometimes it feels very
documentary esthe which is really
riveting for this style because it's a
very grungy and filthy movie and this
style really enhances that and a lot of
that is due to a unhinged performance by
Robert Pattinson who gives his best work
ever
he's really good here and his
performance along with the writing is
actually really ballsy he does and says
things that are considered so
politically incorrect nowadays that you
can't ever say in movies but they're
things that criminals and his position
would do they're not babying one another
when they talk they say filthy things
and they do filthy things there's a
cringe-worthy kissing scene that made my
mouth drop and I haven't felt that way
in a movie in many years it's been a
long time since I've seen a film that
has audacious moments like that that
make you just sit back and be like wait
a second did that really just happen and
while I didn't enjoy looking at it it
gave me a lot of respect for the
filmmakers and there are scenes like
that in this film that make you feel
like you're watching something totally
real that's not Hollywood that's not
with real actors it's just people doing
something dirty and gross and there's
tons of filthy scenes like that that
make you have a respect level for the
filmmakers because Robert Pattinson
scare achter in this film has virtually
nothing redeeming about
he really loves his brother and that's
about it besides that he's pretty much
the scum of the earth and there there's
no amazing arc for him there's no like
glassy Hollywood moment where he sees
the rainbow on the horizon this guy's an
asshole and he's an asshole through the
whole movie and whether or not you can
watch a film like that and be riveted by
a great performance and really good
camera work that's gonna be up to you
I found this film extremely surprising
and really really fresh also really good
in this movie is penny safty one of the
directors who plays his brother and his
work is so good here specifically in an
opening scene that has him answering
these questions from a therapist or a
community aide or someone like that and
you can really see the pain in his face
that he hates his life that he hates
this position he's in and both him and
his brother are just going to try to do
their best to dig themselves out of it
and it's riveting to watch them both try
good time is one of my favorite
thrillers that I've seen in a long time
as for flaws sometimes towards the
middle that can drag a little bit
there's a sequence where Pattinson is
stuck in someone's house for quite some
time and you're wondering when the plots
going to pick up again the first 20 to
30 minutes are essentially perfect in my
opinion there's not a single flaw I
could find and I was on the edge of my
seat
sometimes the film will dip down and
present characters or scenes that don't
really have much interest but they're
letting you know things that happen
previously with new characters who are
being introduced and while the direction
and writing is as I said pretty fresh
and entertaining sometimes the pacing is
an issue it goes from being really
riveting to okay what's going on to
riveting again but still the the neon
drenched look of the city the
documentary esque camerawork really
impressed me I'm gonna give good time
and a - if you guys get a chance to see
this one it has finally expanded into
more theaters definitely check it out
you guys are the best and as always if
you like this you can click right here
and get stubborn eyes
[Music]